merci d'accueillir christian blanc car
ça lui moi j'étais dans les machines à
laver
je vendais des télévisions couleurs noir
et blanc d'abord ça fait un peu vieux
et puis après je suis en fait je suis un
spécialiste du bricolage et des machines
à laver
je connaissais rien au luxe je rentrais
dans lux tout à fait par hasard par
accident un chasseur de têtes comme
d'habitude
alors quand alexandre m'a dit parler de
l'innovation
je vais vous dire dans la dans
l'électronique grand public l'innovation
c'est technologique
j'ai donc débarquer dans lux et là c'est
autre chose d'innovation en fait il ya
trois il ya 3 3 clés pour comprendre le
luxe
je vous la fais court il ya d'abord la
compréhension du client et ça c'est un
sujet majeur surtout aujourd'hui quand
on voit comme les clients évoluent et
comme les clients du luxe change en
particulier dans leurs rapports avec la
avec l'objet beaucoup achètent des
objets pour les revendre dans tout ce
que vous connaissez comme des sites
internet aussi en chine en france comme
vestiaires collective etc
donc on a un décalage entre la la
compréhension de la marque telle qu'elle
est et puis la compréhension de la
marque par les clients tels qu'ils sont
et ce décalage entraîne une perte de
pouvoir sur le luxe sur la marque le
deuxième point très important c'est la
cohérence des marques c'est la cohérence
qui est la clé de la compréhension du
monde de luxe est-ce qu'on est cohérent
est-ce qu'on est incohérent est-ce que
la distribution le marketing
merchandising le service et le produit
sont cohérents et c'est à travers le
prisme de la cohérence et de
l'incohérence que l'on comprend le luxe
et enfin dernier point mais peut-être le
plus important de tous et l'innovation
comment moi j'ai compris d'innovation en
rentrant dans luxe mais j'ai voulu dire
d'abord quand je suis arrivé chez hermès
j'étais donc pdg hermès scellier qui est
la grosse
qui était la fille la plus importante du
groupe et la première chose que j'ai
voulu faire
en fonction ce qu'on m'avait appris non
pas à dauphine mais dans une autre école
de commerce
certainement moins bien mais quand même
pas si mauvaise là on m'a on m'avait dit
tu es était important parce que tu es
pdg du décide alors j'ai pensé qu'une
des premières choses que je voulais
faire c'est d'aller dans les vitrines en
particulier dans celle du faubourg
saint-honoré pour un m1 pour que les
vitrines et des produits qu'ils
m'aideraient à faire mon budget des
choses simples qu'on vous apprend des
choses simples que j'avais bien apprise
en travaillant avec darty en travaillant
avec la fnac
lorsque j'entendais des télés c'est
quand même important de mettre en
vitrine des produits qui vous aide à
réaliser vos objectifs
donc je suis allé voir la dame qui
dirigeait les vitrines qui s'appelle
leila menchari et je lui ai dit leila
voilà je suis de toute évidence chez
votre boss j'ai pas dit cette bêtise là
mais je suis quand même pas nul à ce
point là mais j'ai expliqué quand même
que j'étais là à ce qu'elle savait et
que j'aimerai bien que j'aurais bien
aimé qu'elle met des produits que
j'arrivais pas très bien la vendée que
je voudrais qu'elle épouse quoi alors
elle m'a regardé puis elle m'a dit ben
massa sera non jeune homme c'est très
ennuyeux quand vous sortez d'une école
de commerce
hadji dia sera nous mais pourquoi ce
sera nous alors elle m'a dit mais ça
sera nous je serais pas ce que vous
dites je mettrais ce que je veux j'ai
dit mais c'est pas du tout la règle je
dois vous dire on va rentrer ce que mon
ego elle a pris un bon coup là je me
suis dit 'mon sites auront chacun bosse
bien alors suis allé voir le le
président de l'entreprise qui s'appelait
jean louis dumas qui était propriétaire
d'hermès
si je lui ai dit j'ai envie s'il ya un
koala gros problème quand même elle veut
pas alors il m'a répondu mais c'est toi
qui comprend rien dit comment rien rien
du tout il faut que tu apprennes coco
qui vend plus de téléviseurs
tdans luxe et elle elle fait ce qu'elle
veut et c'est la règle et elle a fait ce
qu'elle a voulu
quelques mois plus tard l'ambassadeur
des états unis l'appel et il me dit et
il m'appelle mois six fois
ceux-ci qu'est-ce qui me veut je le
rappelle et me voilà ce qui m'est arrivé
monsieur je suis ambassadeur des états
unis
je viens du texas je me suis dit c'est
un mauvais poids ça il doit être un peu
un peu lourdingue
alors il me dit je viens du texas
je suis allé avec l'ambassade ats-unis
juste en face d'hermès la résidence
je suis allé dans la vitrine devant la
vitrine j'ai voulu acheter pour
l'anniversaire de ma femme
bon ça que j'ai appelé six fois c'est
pas cesser demain à jeudi avec une
urgence c'est pas fait rare qu'on
m'appelle six fois l'ambassadeur
d'étagés oui ma femme oui parce qu'il ya
toujours des urgences mais par
l'ambassadeur des états unis alors il me
dit voilà j'ai voulu acheter ce sac
on m'a répondu non j'ai demandé le nom
du président il paraît que c'est vous
dit c'est moi alors je me sens que c'est
tout je veux pas discuter jeu ça que je
le paye et je vais l'acheter je le veux
et j'étais obligée d'y estime qu'il ya
juste un problème il faut que je vous
rappelle je suis donc allé voir leïla
menchari la même lilas manjari et je lui
dis lilas il faut l'ambassade des états
unis il faut lui vendre le sac
elle m'a dit non web non web non web aux
pauvres christian norway tu l'auras pas
le sac
c'est pourquoi je n'aurais pas tu
l'auras pas parce que j'ai fait faire ce
sac exprès pour la vitrine mais pas pour
le vendre pour que les gens souhaitent
l'acheter ne trouve jamais parce qu'il
est à moissac
je veux la voir pour mes prochaines
vitrine qui auront lieu dans trois ans
car dans trois ans je vais récupérer son
sac
donc ton ambassadeur c'est le pape ou
l'ambassadeur je m'en fous eh ben ça oui
la portance tu auras pas donc j'ai
rappelé l'ambassadeur la queue basse
quand même et je lui ai dit je vais
ambassadeur je peux pas me dit vous
rigolez vous êtes si yo vous êtes sion
vous êtes le patron est prêt pas me
vendre 1 sec
non non je ne peux pas je ne peux pas
parce que parce que c'est comme ça chez
nous il ya des zones d'innovation rage
option empêtré dans des explications
incompréhensible pour un mec du texas
et qui n'a pas du reste avaler et
compris heureusement j'étais
l'accueillir je veux dire on va vous
achetez un autre sac qu'il en a fini par
en acheter un en réalité je conclus sur
ce sujet d'innovation en vous disant
trois choses d'abord c'est absolument
fondamental l'innovation mais c'est
quand on a dit ça on n'a rien dit
la vraie question que je me suis posée
est la vraie question que j'ai analysé
et j'essaie à laquelle j'essaie de
répondre c'est comment on organise
l'innovation comment on général
innovation dans une entreprise comme
celle du luxe où l'innovation et la
créativité sont à la base même du succès
puisqu'il n'y a pas d'innovation
technologique il faut en trouver une
autre
et ma réponse puisque j'ai très peu de
temps excellent
le principe de ce de ce type d'exposer
ma réponse tourne autour de 3 2 3
trois types d'actions quoi la première
qui va vous surprendre
c'est que je crois beaucoup à la à
l'absence de l'hiérarchie dans la dans
la g dans la façon de générer
l'innovation c'est à dire qu'il faut
créer ce que nous ce que j'ai souvent
fait des zones de non-droit des zones où
la hiérarchie n'intervient pas des zones
où vous avez le droit de créer 100 sans
avoir de contraintes financières ou de
contrainte de temps ou de contraintes de
la logique des affaires en fait il faut
quitter la logique habituelle des
affaires dont il faut mettre au panier
tout ce qu'on vous enseigne en clair où
tout ce que j'ai reçu pour créer des
zones où finalement vous n'avez pas de
pouvoir y'a pas de pouvoir hiérarchique
c'est exactement ça qu'on a fait avec
leïla menchari quand elle crée des scot
elle demande des sacs qu'elle est créé à
sa façon qui sont parqués particulière
des sactions de vendre à jamais elle est
dans une zone de non droit et nous avons
fait ça assez souvent pour générer
l'innovation en deux comme si la
hiérarchie pouvait parfois être
communautaire etc à travers des
communautés on pouvait accéder à des
idées nouvelles ce qui est vraiment le
coeur du business les idées nouvelles
l'innovation dans les stands dans les
formes dans les couleurs dans les dents
là dans l'est dans le toucher dans le
respirer
c'est dans l'essence est très difficile
à générer ça c'est le premier pas créer
des zones où rien ou tout est possible
la deuxième chose que je dois vous dire
c'est que je crois beaucoup au
comportement des dirigeants pour générer
de l'innovation parce que si vous
dirigez une entreprise avec avait en
générant la crainte de l'échec et vous
même si vous êtes un espèce de deux
parapluies ennuyeux qui croient aux
belles formules est qui et qui n'accepte
que les gens qui vous ressemble qui
recrute que des gens de dauphine
quel ennui donc et vous devez généré je
parle de dauphine parce que vous êtes là
mais c'est pire avec hec et l'essec et
donc vous coptes entre atroce donc si
vous voulez il faut vraiment que les
dirigeants et pas je vous donne un
exemple
un jour on a fait l'année de la musique
chez hermès et puis l'année de la
musique on s'est mis à tous avoir des
leçons musique dans tous les magasins
partout on a chanté tout le monde a
chanté pendant un an je me suis dit moi
qui dirige l'entreprise comment je vais
faire quoi
d'abord chante comme une casserole et
puis je me suis dit comment j'ai fait ce
que je participe
alors finalement avec une jeune femme
d'hermès ont réalisé tous les deux
participé
on a pris un cours on a pris des cours
de chant pendant un an parce que
franchement c'est difficile d'apprendre
d'une chanson et puis quand tout a quand
on a fait cette grande réunion au buddha
bar où tous les magasins les plus
performants sont venus chanter à la fin
ils ont lit puis maintenant on a un
petit numéro avec deux personnes des
professionnels qui viennent d'ailleurs
et c est moi je suis descendu devant le
cas les actionnaires et c'est avec un
bandana en rockeur et puis je me suis
mis à chanter
ben goldman j'avais choisi golman vous
avez la chanson de golman là la balle
sinon là bas tout terrain et tout est
possible
vous connaissez ça tout est juste
étreint la vivre continent sans grillage
là-bas tout est possible à mon âge de
sept cas de le dire du reste et on s'est
mis à chanter comme ça
et en fait pourquoi pour créer encore la
même chose la même idée un décalage
ça c'est la 2e 2e deuxième condition
l'innovation si vous créez pas des
décalages si on vous voit sous un prisme
munich quand vous dirigez entreprises
comment voulez vous que les gens enough
ils sont juste point c or il faut
décoincer les attitudes mais comment et
puis il faut l'ouvrir à ce qu'ils sont
comptables innovation n'appartient pas à
une catégorie particulière mais à tous
en tous les cas dans lux le troisième
point pour générer l'innovation qui m'a
toujours frappé c'est au fond de
partager beaucoup plus qu'on le fait
l'esprit de groupe
en fait pas seulement d'être d'avoir
comme dirigeant d attitude décalée mais
aussi de faire des choses vis qui avec
les autres
je vous donne un exemple concret lorsque
l'an 2000 est arrivé moi j'ai décidé
d'emmener tous les cadres d'hermès à new
york ils étaient 350 dont 200 n'avait
pas de passeport
parce que dans les cadres on peut aussi
les contremaîtres cadres et assimilés
cadre on est tous partis sur six boeing
arrivé à new york et là on a fait une
fête énorme
j'avais réservé des chambres pour une
nuit parce qu'on devait le lendemain
avait une réunion de travail à 8h dans
le magasin hermès de new york madison et
j'avais dit à 300 ou 300 personnes après
le dîner vous faites ce que vous voulez
fierté des chambres je suis allé me
coucher vers 11h30 et le matin à 6
heures du matin quand sept heures du
matin quand je me suis levé toute la
région étaient à 8 heures j'ai vu le
directeur de l'hôtel qui m'a dit
monsieur monsieur dites moi vous avez
réservé 300 chambres
si c'est bien sûr mais il y en a que 80
qui ont été occupées mais c'est bien
inquiétant
c'est bien inquiétant si l'on fait la
fête comme des vagues dans toutes ses
potes de new york
j'avais prévenu à six à huit heures vous
n'êtes pas là ça va être ça va être le
bordel à 8 heures ils étaient là tous il
n'en manquait pas
après analyse on est allé sur l'hudson
river pour chanter danser
j'essaie tout semble hélas et puis après
on est rentré et le lendemain ils
étaient appareils c'est une action de
fou mais c'est une action formidable
l'innovation ça suppose quand même qu'on
soit un peu dingue mais qu'on soit aussi
très réaliste
si on veut l'innovation que la taille du
business il faut vraiment être un peu
différent merci